η οποία λέει κάποια πράγματα ότι αν καιφόσον εξασφαλιστή διαβατήριον θα τεθεί στην στη διάθεση
τουμοσπον διακό πρόμον ιδί λαμβάνοντας εκόψεην ότι έχουμενίδη τώρα τον τάραργουήλισε οποίος αγγωνίζεται ως να
τουραλιζέ με τον οποίον έχουμε μια άψωκαι συν αργασία είναι φοβερός πεκτήση και αυτός τα
δίνει όλα άρα έχει να κάνειμε τη διαθεσιμότητα και το ποιος θα είναι σε καλύτερη
αν καιφόσον εξασφαλήσει ώρα το διαπατήριο και θα ωφέλει κι να περάσουμε λίγο σταθετικά και
τα οθέλει της διοργάνωσης στο γυρό πά κε για τη χώρα μας εμείς το χωρίζουμε
ησεδύο είναι τα θλητικά οφέλει ποχούν να κάνουν με τι συμμετωχή της εθνικής όμαδας ανδρών
συντελική φάση πρώτη φραστην ιστορία κανέναν άλλο νομαδικόν άθρημα δε έχει υπαέξει σε τελική φάσι
άρα το ένα το κομμάτι ν είναι το καλάθοσφερικών το οποίον το αγωνιστικών το οποίον
ογόθε το πρώτον πάνω στο φέλι δηλατή στη λήστα μουμε τοφέλει αυτόν είναι το νούμερον
ένα διότι απο δώ προσπαθού θα θα προσπαθήσουμε να επενδήσουμε και να κεφάλω υπιήσουμε όλον
όλο ν αυτόν το οποιον ικνεται και χαίρομε που σ στον τελευταίο να γόνα της
εθνικής γιατί έχεις δει τ ότι έχει ξεκινήσει να γίνεται και το πως συνδεται πλέων
ο κόσμος με αυτόν το γεγονός αλλά ιδιαίτερα με την αθυνικί νομάα γίνονται κάποια πράγματα
οποία έπρεπε να γίνο και στη χώρα μας όπως για παράδειγμα να βρίσκεται κόσμος γύρω
από το από το γύπεδο όχι πάνω στις καιερκίδες να υπάρχειυνείναι αυτό που είπαμε ανέσεις
σε σαγωγικά τα ι αλλαγή σε κάποια πράγματα για να ρκαρτήσουν και τον κόσμοναι δεν
είναι μπονώ ν αυτό αυτό ξεκίνηση και από τον προηγούμενον παράθύρο με τη βοσθνία με
τους αστέρες που ήρθα γιατί τότε μπορούσαν και ήρθν και ήρθεν και ομοοομόσα είναι το
νομερον αυτή τη θυμείνει το ότι πιο χόκυκλοφορεί νομίζω ακουσακατι γίνεται μολιπιαγ αλλά δεξέροσηπορα πηρέως
ναι λοιπόν και είδαμε ο κόσμος χειροκρώτησεν την προσπάθεια τη διάθεση εναίμασταν κοντά όλο προμονίδής
της βοσίνειας είπεν ότι έπρεπε να βάλουν